حسنًا، نظام تجريبي لسرطان الجلد،
نظام يظهر نتائج واعدة
في مكافحة سرطان الجلد،
يجمع العلاج بين لقاح mRNA الجديد والعلاج
المناعي، أظهرت أحدث النتائج من
دراسة أجريت على مرضى معرضين لمخاطر عالية
انخفاض احتمالات
انتشار سرطان الجلد أو عودته بعد
ظهوره.  تمت إزالة هذه الأخبار الرائعة، لقد
انضمت إلينا الآن ميج تيريل من CNN،
وأخبرنا ميج عن هذا
اللقاح التجريبي وما وجده ومدى
فعاليته، ومدى فعاليته،
مثير للغاية، نعم، أنت تعلم أنه حقًا ما
نفكر فيه في مادنا  بالطبع باعتبارك صانع
لقاح فيروس كورونا MRNA، وهذه
فكرة مشابهة حقًا، فأنت تقوم بشكل أساسي
بتوصيل التعليمات الجينية إلى
الجسم لتدريب جهاز المناعة أه
لمحاربة العدو بشكل أفضل في هذه الحالة أه،
فهي مصممة بشكل فردي لتناسب كل
مريض بالسرطان  في الواقع، يأخذون
عينة من السرطان ويقومون بتسلسلها
ويقررون باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي ما هي أفضل مجموعة
من توقيعات mRNA
ثم يعطون
العلاج الفردي للمريض ويقومون بتدريب
جهاز المناعة لديهم لمحاربة السرطان بشكل أفضل ويقومون بذلك  "
إننا نفعل هذا بالإضافة إلى
دواء العلاج المناعي القوي جدًا والذي تمت
الموافقة عليه بالفعل والذي يسمى K truda وما
وجدوه في هذه المتابعة لمدة ثلاث سنوات
هو أن هذا المزيج قلل من
خطر عودة السرطان أو
وفاة المرضى بمقدار النصف تقريبًا وهذا
حقًا  من المهم أن يكون لدينا
الآن بيانات مدتها ثلاث سنوات لأنها تظهر
أن هذا العلاج متين بالفعل، وفي
السابق لم نشاهد سوى متابعة لمدة عامين فقط
الآن من حيث الآثار الجانبية،
فهي في الواقع متشابهة إلى حد كبير من حيث
الآثار الأكثر شيوعًا لما  تشعر بالتعب أثناء
حقن لقاح فيروس كورونا والألم
والقشعريرة الآن كنت أتحدث
مع الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة Madna هذا الصباح ستيفان
بونسل وكان يقول إن الشركة
تستعد على الأرجح ليكون هذا
متاحًا في أقرب وقت بحلول عام 2025، فهم يقومون
ببناء مصنع تصنيع جديد هنا
في  من المحتمل أن تكون الولايات المتحدة في ماساتشوستس
مستعدة لذلك قريبًا، والسرطان
الجلدي ليس هو الشيء الوحيد الذي
يسعون إليه هنا، فقد بدأوا أيضًا
تجارب المرحلة المتأخرة على نوع معين من
سرطان الرئة أيضًا، لذلك هناك أمل
بالطبع في أن هذا الأمر مفتوح حقًا  أه
طرق أفضل لمحاربة السرطان على
المستوى الشخصي